أشعر نوعًا ما كما لو كان من المفترض أن أكون
أعمى لمجرد أن أكون قادرًا على رؤية الأشياء
من وجهة نظر مختلفة تمامًا ،
فقد تطلب الأمر بعض الشجاعة لاستخدام أدوات مختلفة ،
لكن عندما أعمل على قطعة من
الخشب ، أشعر بسلام شديد ، فقد حصلت على مثل هذا
السائل  أشعر أنه يشبه
كلبًا آخر تقريبًا يمكنني أن أشعر به يتدفق
ويتغير ثم أطفئه وأعلن
أنه وعاء مزخرف جميل
نشأت في بلدة صغيرة في كولورادو
شعرت أنني لم أكن مناسبًا حقًا كثيرًا
هناك
لقد بدأت بالفعل  جعلني أشعر
بالاكتئاب ، لذلك عندما كنت في السادسة عشرة من عمري حاولت
الانتحار بإطلاق النار على نفسي ، لم أعد أرغب
في مواجهة العالم بعد الآن كلما
فكرت في الأمر كلما تقدمت في السن كلما قل
معنى ذلك لحسن الحظ أنني فقدت فقط
حاسة البصر والشم  وتركت
عقلي سليمًا تمامًا ،
لقد تعلمت النجارة بعد ثماني سنوات من
إصابتي بالعمى ، ذهبت إلى
مركز تدريب للمكفوفين
بدأت بالذهاب إلى متجر الأخشاب
واكتشفت أنني أمتلك موهبة في ذلك ، كما
تعلمون ، لم أفكر مطلقًا في النجارة
بعد أن كنت  بلي  لكني علمت
أن هناك بالفعل مجتمعًا كبيرًا جدًا
من عمال النجارة المكفوفين ، لقد كان أمرًا
لا يصدق بالنسبة لي ، لقد فتحت
لي
زوجتي آني في نواح كثيرة
، لقد كانت جزءًا هائلاً من
أعمال النجارة الخاصة بي وهي تساعدني  اختر
ألوانًا مختلفة من الخشب لشيء واحد ،
لكنها أيضًا هي التي اشترت لي
مخرطتي التي تدعمني بكل
طريقة وكانت جزءًا رائعًا من
حياتي ، أعني هنا في ورشتي الخشبية
حوالي ست ساعات معظم الأيام ولا أستطيع
أخبرك كم هو لطيف عندما أكون هنا
مغطى برقائق الخشب ، أبدأ
بقطعة الخشب الخشنة الخاصة بي وأقوم بقياسها
وأرى هل سيصنع هذا وعاءًا أو علبة
أو طبق مجوهرات هو الأفضل من هناك.
برنامج التصميم في
ذهني أسميه لا يزال خيالي مرئيًا للغاية ،
كما تعلم ، قم بتقطيعه إلى كتلة قابلة للاستخدام
على المنشار بشكل أساسي إذا
اتبعت القواعد العمياء أو المبصر ، احتفظ بيدي
حيث من المفترض أن تكون منشارًا يعمل
مثل المنشار  وليس هناك الكثير مما
يمكنك فعله  ثم أقوم
بتثبيتها على المخرطة وتحويلها إلى
قطعة فنية
أحب الأصوات التي تصدرها عندما تقوم
بنحت قطع مختلفة ستصدر
أصواتًا مختلفة ، وبعد
ذلك سأفعلها بشكل صحيح وأنا  جعل
القطع الكاسح في وعاء هو مجرد نوع
من التمرير ، أشعر بالخشب وهو
يدور بيدي اليسرى وقد نحتت
باليد اليمنى ويمكنني الشعور به
يتحول تحت أصابعي بينما أقوم
بقطع الخشب بعيدًا  الإزميل
يمكنني تحويل جذع من الخشب الخام
إلى قطعة فنية تشبه
الفخار الخشبي
، كما لو كنت تشعر بأن الحياة
فيه تحتوي على هذا النوع من السحر لأنه
كان أحد أكثر
الأشياء التي غيّرت الحياة بشكل أساسي  بالنسبة لي لأن
لدي شيئًا أجيده
وينتج شيئًا في النهاية